in a little less than an hour but bells
will toll first in Memphis and then
around the world to mark the 50th
anniversary of the assassination of
Martin Luther King jr. correspondent
Jonathan Serrie reports on the
observances from Memphis thousands
gathered in Memphis to commemorate the
50th anniversary of the assassination of
dr. Martin Luther King jr. when I was 16
years of age touch my life every
director my belt and today I'm looking
at the celebrated voices of young people
around the United States of America
again I felt on April 3 1968 King and
his entourage came to Memphis to support
striking sanitation workers he rallied
them with his I've been to the
mountaintop speech the following evening
civil rights leader and former UN
ambassador Andrew Young remembers joking
around with King back at their motel I
said something smart and he picked up a
pill and threw it at me and I threw it
back and then everybody picked up
hillier I'd beaten me up and it was like
this was the happiest moment I had seen
moments later King stepped onto the
balcony outside room 306 of the Lorraine
Motel when a shot fired from a window of
a boarding house across the street
I saw his shoes stuck in the grate and I
ran up the steps and realized that that
he'd been shot and he was laying there
in a puddle of blood the sight of King's
assassination is now preserved as part
of the National Civil Rights Museum
prediction of the way King's youngest
daughter Bernice toward a new exhibit
honoring her father's life as with many
she comes to this place not just to
remember what happened half a century
ago
but to celebrate the enduring impact
King continues to have on American
society he left us and Chris the
National Civil Rights Museum is going to
mark the moment King was assassinated
601 p.m. Central Time by ringing a bell
and then in two minute increments bells
will begin to toll throughout the city
of Memphis and then nationally and then
around the world Chris Jonathan Serrie
reporting tonight from Memphis Jonathan
thank you